House Speaker Paul Ryan says
middle-class families will see a tax cut
of nearly $1,200 under the new
Republican plan
the House bill reduces a number of tax
brackets from seven to four the proposal
increase increases rather standard
deductions and expands the child tax
credit but it largely eliminates popular
state and local tax deductions and
limits mortgage interest deductions the
House Ways and Means Committee will take
up the bill
this Monday CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here to break it all
down what this tax overhaul means for
your family good morning to you Jill
good morning so let's start with the
brackets going from seven to four
already sounds simpler and better is
there a but two that well there is a bit
of a but it's 12 25 35 and 39% and
remember everybody I know you look at
those numbers but we have a progressive
tax system so if you see this look at
this for individuals you make up to
$45,000
you pay 12% the next 45 to 200,000 jumps
to 25% and so on so what's good about
this is it is a simplification but what
you'll also notice that that 39.6% rate
that's still in there that wasn't going
to be in there it's applied to much
higher income so yes indeed the middle
class is likely to be helped by this but
if you make a lot of money you're gonna
get helped by a lot more what about
doubling the standard deduction well
what's interesting about this doing that
is that if essentially if you make less
than $24,000 you're not going to pay tax
so that seems really great and when you
claim the standard deduction tax filing
is far easier right now about 70% of
filers claim the standard deduction
under this new plan it looks like it's
gonna jump to 84 percent so that's good
it's easier but there's a caveat here in
doubling the standard deduction the plan
will also get rid of personal exemptions
that's what you've claimed four grand
for yourself for your spouse and for
your kids if your middle-class family
and you've got a bunch of kids this plan
may not be so good for you so it's a
very strange plan because it's quite
particular to each person's situation so
you're saying essentially because this
plan would also increase the child tax
credit if I'm married and I have kids
which I don't but if I
or what would this mean for me go get
some kids it goes from a thousand
sixteen hundred dollars Vlad yeah well
let's talk about that this is going to
be a family tax credit so from $1,000
per child goes to sixteen hundred that's
very helpful also it expands the income
range by which you can qualify for that
you'll also get a three hundred dollar
deduction if you are talking taking care
of it maybe an elderly relative again
this really is focused on your family
and by the way where you live it's
extraordinarily important yeah I think
some I think it's fair to say some of
the most controversial stuff will be the
repealing of the state and local tax
deductions and limiting of the home
interest mortgage deduction right right
so here's what goes on right now if you
itemize your taxes currently you can
deduct your state and local taxes
against your federal return under the
new plan you can no longer do that but
you can actually deduct property taxes
that's capped at ten thousand dollars so
what's happening right now is the
National Association of Homebuilders the
National Association of Realtors is
against this plan because they believe
those deductions help the housing market
and again the mortgage interest
deduction very important if you have a
mortgage relax you're grandfathered in
new mortgages interest is only
deductible up to a five hundred thousand
dollar mortgage this is very important
it looks like it's also going to apply
to refight complicated plan very much
depends on where you live
gotta go but bottom line who benefits
most the ultra wealthy and I mean the
ultra wealthy all right Joe thank you
very much